bon
[Musique]
des cherche
cherche on entre
mais des chercheurs qui trouvent ça on
en cherche connaissez probablement des
gens qui font ce genre de blagues à
propos de la recherche scientifique je
pense qu'ils n'ont pas vraiment compris
de quoi il parle
bonjour je m'appelle antoine fournier et
ce soir je vous parlais de recherche
scientifique
alors non pas en tant que chercheur
moi-même longtemps que vulgarisateur sur
la chaîne youtube de spirent pour
commencer sa surprendra personne
si je dis que la science est d'abord une
affaire de curiosité qui résiste et qui
nous pousse à observer le monde qui nous
entoure et le demander pourquoi ça se
passe comme ça et pour la même raison
qu'un film inspiré de faits réels attire
notre attention
parler de science s'est parlé de faits
de chose prouver et cette proximité avec
le réel rend les choses concrètes est
vrai pour nous donc parler de science
sait parler de réalité
mais comme le disait le docteur henry
jones dans la dernière croisade
l'archéologie et la recherche d'effets
pas de la vérité
il n'avait pas tort et cette distinction
entre réalité fait et vérité est
vachement intéressante et je pense
qu'elle dépasse le cadre de
l'archéologie pour s'appliquer à
l'ensemble des domaines scientifiques
dans la suite de ce talk je vais vous
parler de cette relation entre recherche
scientifique et vérité en parlant de mon
animal préféré
le dragon de komodo alors pour petit
rappel les varans de komodo sont juste
les plus gros varan du monde donc des
espèces incroyables qui peuvent mesurer
3 mètres de long et peser 90 kg donc
c'est des dimensions absolument hors
norme a largement de quoi faire de
l'audience avec un reportage télévisé ou
intrigué les curieux pendant un ted
talks
mais une chose qu'on oublie souvent un
propos du dragon de komodo
c'est que le monde occidental n'a
découvert son existence que dans les
années 1910 donc il n'ya pas si
longtemps en fait et c'est pas très
étonnant quand on sait qu'ils le peuple
que cinq petites îles d'indonésie
centrale dont l'île de komodo qui lui a
donné son nom
un peu plus tôt je vous parlais de
curiosité alors vous en conviendrez il
ya peu de choses sur terre qui attire
autant la curiosité qu'un lézard géant
mangeurs de buffles et donc
rapidement à la découverte de cet animal
vu son succès et sa rareté effectué 11
ont commencé à circuler à son sujet
notamment il ya un suédois en 1937 qui
raconte avoir vu un spécimen de 7 mètres
de long
sept mètres de haut donc au début du
siècle passé on raconte un peu tout et
n'importe quoi à propos du dragons du
komodo et dans ce contexte de doutes et
d'incertitudes
un herpétologue donc rien avec les rps
ainsi quelqu'un qui étudie les reptiles
du nom de walter hoffenberg décide
soixante ans après la découverte de
l'animal de lancer une vaste expédition
pour l'observer dans son écosystème
naturel collecter des spécimens à
l'objectif est clair c'est collecter un
maximum de fait possible sur l'animal
pour tirer au clair les légendes qui
circulent sur le dragon de komodo
nous voilà donc en 1969 et le bon
docteur samba s'installer sur l'île de
komodo avec toute sa famille et commence
à observer tous les jours des lézards
donc ils observent tout ce qui est à peu
près observable leur morphologie leur
anatomie leur écologie
leur comportement est entre autres
choses leur mode de prédation c'est ce
dernier point qui va faire couler
beaucoup d'encre et qui va nous
intéresser dans la suite de cette
présentation
voyez c'est un peu comme une sorte de
cluedo aux propos du dragon de komodo
je vous pose l énigme on sait que le
dragons du komodo se nourri de carcasses
de façon opportuniste mais il lui arrive
de chasser alors selon la taille de sa
cible il s'éprend de différentes
manières si c'est un petit animal comme
un jeune enfant
ils attaquent à la nuque pour l'amener
au sol si par contre c'est une proie de
taille plus importante comme un cerf
adultes voire même un buffle là ils
attaquent plutôt les membres inférieurs
dans l'espoir de le faire tomber
alors vous devinerez que plus la taille
de sa cible est grande - il est rare que
celle ci s'échappe à son attaque
logique mais c'est là que hoffenberg
constate quelque chose de curieux
même si des petits veinards parviennent
à s'échapper aux attaques du dragon de
komodo dépérissent et ils finissent par
mourir dans les jours voire les heures
qui fut cette attaque
donc là on
on connaît le meurtrier on connaît la
victime mais l'arme du crime reste
mystère donc première hypothèse que vous
pourrez penser c'est probablement à
cause de venin c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a
pensé walter et il a inspecté la
mâchoire des dragons du komodo mais n'a
trouvé ni crochet ni petit canot dans
les dents de l'animal qui servirait à
inoculer du revenant comme on en trouve
par exemple chez les serpents
du coup il écarte cette hypothèse en
plus les symptômes qu'ils voient se
développer chez les animaux ressemble
pour lui à une infection bactérienne
généralisée il note ses observations de
son carnet est pour lui une
interprétation se dessine alors les
dragons du komodo aurait une hygiène
dentaire tellement déplorable que quand
il croque une proie il inocule des
bactéries qui vont provoquer à terme sa
mort ce qui est chouette hypothèse nous
on a déjà des animaux les plus
charismatiques du monde mais en plus il
tue ses proies avec une arme
bactériologique place mais bon ça c'est
une observation naturaliste qu'on a
c'est pas une preuve un protocole
scientifique rigoureux voudrait qu'on
met tout ça à l'épreuve dans des
conditions contrôlées pas de problème en
2002 montgomery un scientifique et son
équipe publie justement des recherches à
ce sujet il compare des dragons du
komodo captifs et sauvage à l'aide de
prélèvements de salive première
expérience il analyse la salive des
dragons du komodo et recherche des
bactéries à l'intérieur ils vont
dénombré pas moins de 57 espèces
différentes de bactéries choses
rigolotes qui avait entre deux et trois
fois plus d'espèces de bactéries dans la
bouche des dragons du komodo sauvage que
dans la bouche d'un conte du komodo
captifs sont biologiques vu les
conditions d'hygiène dans lesquelles il
était donc oui ya bel et bien des
bactéries dans la série des dragons du
komodo
encore faut-il démontrer le pouvoir
pathogène de ces bactéries pour ça
qu'ils prennent la salive la dilue avec
un peu d'eau et l'injectent dans des
souris les scientifiques aiment bien ça
dans les résultats ne se font pas
attendre 40 % des souris meurent de
l'injection et celles qui survivent
présente tout même des symptômes de
pathologies de notre côté il prenne
cette dilution la passe dans un filtre
qui en retirent les bactéries
l'injectent dans d'autres souris et la
peau de mortalité donc il semblerait
bien que ce soit ces bactéries qui soit
à l'origine du pouvoir pathogène
en plus pour enfoncer le clou de notre
affaire il analyse le sens de souris qui
ont été tués par l'injection et il
trouve la présence d'une bactérie
pasteures et la multi sida bactéries qui
était justement présente dans la bouche
d'un des dragons du komodo sauvage
bon là c'est comme si on avait trouvé le
criminel avec encore l'arme du crime
dans la main l'afer est résolu le
dragons du komodo tuent ses victimes
avec des bactéries présentes dans sa
salive ou peut-être pas en 2006 paraît
un article sur la classification des
reptiles qui va pas mal bouleverser
notre enquête pour mettre dans le
contexte les biologistes depuis le début
de la biologie adore classer les espèces
vivantes mais depuis les travaux de
charles darwin on sait que classer les
espèces selon leur proximité génétique
et anatomiques revient à révéler leur
parenté dans l'histoire évolutive
en gros si vous voulez plus en place
deux espèces proches plus à sont
évolutives mans proches
est ce que les résultats de bryan fry et
son équipe semblent démontrer c'est que
au sein des reptiles l'ensemble de ceux
qui sont équipés de venin des angles
tous d'un même ancêtre commun qui avait
lui aussi des glandes à venin
ancestrales et au sein de ce groupe qui
s'appelait les toxicos ferrat on trouve
du coup sans surprise les serpents mais
aussi les warrants dont notre dragons du
komodo vous en doutez l'hypothèse sur le
mode de prédation du dragon de komodo
cas bryan fry est assez différente de
celle qui a prévalu pendant presque un
siècle que faire du coût de ce que
disait walter hoffenberg qui avait
justement écarté cette hypothèse parce
qu'ils avaient décroché ni canots dans
les dents justement en 2009 donc trois
ans après ce papier sur la
classification bryan fry publie ses
recherches et expose sa théorie en trois
principaux arguments que je vais vous
présenter
premièrement y publient une image irm de
la tête des dragons du komodo et bingo
il révèle la présence de glandes à venin
donc elles sont là et elles sont assez
originales si vous voulez à se trouve
dans la mâchoire inférieure de l'animal
et ne débouchent ni d'en décrocher ni
d'un des canots dans les dents mais
directement dans la cavité buccale de
l'animal en sortant entre les dents pour
ça qu'il avait rien vu auteurs ensuite
deuxième argument
il inspecte la structure de la mâchoire
et de la tenture des dragons du komodo
il arrive à modéliser par exemple la
force de morsure d'un dragon
et chose surprenante il semble capable
de déployer une force de morsures
relativement faibles comparés à des
animaux qui chassent des proies de
taille comparable
par contre elles semblent étonnamment
résistantes à la tension ce que ça
suggère c'est que la stratégie du dragon
de komodo est plutôt de croquer sa proie
et de tirer violemment pour ouvrir de
larges plaies large plaie par lesquels
pour éventuellement s'infiltre et un
venant square en troisième et dernier
argument ils prélèvent une glande à
venin sur un des dragons du komodo
captifs et parviennent à analyser les
toxines qui la renferme entre autres
joyeusetés on est sur un venin qui par
exemple provoque des baisses de
l'attention et qu'ils aient des
propriétés anticoagulantes pour le son
ils ont trouvé que des doses de 0,1 mg
de toxines par kilogramme de proies
provoque une sévère hypotension et les
deux de 0,4 mg par kg pour carrément un
commun je vais apprendre
ils ont trouvé que les dragons du komodo
adultes moyens pouvait déployer lors
d'une attaque jusqu'à 40 milligrammes de
toxines et comme leurs proies
habituelles son dessert dont les adultes
pèsent 40 kg pour les plonger eux dans
le coma faudrait leur injecter 16 mg de
toxines donc ça paraît tout à fait
cohérent avec ce que l'animal est
capable de faire ok donc là on a re
résolu l'anc est en fait je dragons du
komodo chasse à l'aide d'un savon
arsenal mais n'en des dents acérées une
mâchoire résistants l'attention et des
glandes à venin sait toujours pas
toujours pas parce que rappelez vous
tout début de cette présentation je
disais que les dragons du komodo pouvais
attaquer des buffles bien les buffles
ces animaux qui peuvent peser plus de
500 kg dont pour les plonger eux dans le
coma il faudrait leur injecter 200 mg de
toxines jose que le dragons du komodo ne
peut tout simplement pas faire too cool
on est un peu bloquée qu'est ce qu'on
fait venin ou bactéries alors ça se
résout pas avec un vote la science un
avantage qui est que les observations
qui elles sont faites de façon
méticuleuse sont fiables
c'est leur interprétation qui peut être
sujette à débat du coup les recherches
les plus récentes en fait ne valide pas
les résultats qui ont pu être collectés
par le passé et peuvent bouleverser
l'interprétation qu'on en est de cette
façon
oui montgomerie avait effectivement
prouvé le pouvoir pathogène de bactéries
comme pasteur et la mule de sida ça
paraît assez évident par contre là où
c'est un petit peu chaud c'est de
supposer que ces bactéries là qui
étaient inoccupés par le varan parce
qu'en fait on avait trouvé que seulement
1 des spécimens aux dragons du komodo
sauvage qui avait cette bactérie dans sa
bouche un peu léger quand même ce qu'on
suggère aujourd'hui c'est que le dragons
du komodo lorsqu'il attaque ses proies
injecte son venin mais dans la plupart
des cas ça suffit à la tuer directement
ou al ahly mobiliser suffisamment pour
que le dragons du komodo puisse faire
son repas
mais si ça ne suffit pas et que la proie
s'échappe à ce moment là les propriétés
anticoagulantes du venin entre en jeu ça
empêche la plaie de cicatriser et du
coup ça en fait la porte ouverte à
l'entrée de tous les agents pathogènes
de l'environnement dont pastore la
muette au sida qui est justement une
bactérie commune de l'environnement du
dragons du komodo
est-ce que du coup des chercheurs comme
montgomery ou même comme hoffenberg
étaient des mauvais chercheurs des
mauvais scientifique qui trouve pas bah
non pas forcément
c'est leur recherche était dans le réel
bryan fry a juste relativiser
l'importance de la bactérie en apportant
le venin comme élément nouveau dans l'
enquête
et oui des animaux meurent de septicémie
après les attaques nous avons du komodo
mais pas d'une bactérie inoculé par le
varan de komodo mais plutôt des effets
secondaires du venin qui leur ouvre la
porte
donc cette interprétation qu'on a à la
fin du mode de prédation du dragon de
komodo semble assez cohérente avec
l'ensemble tout ce qui a été observé
pendant plus d'un siècle sur l'animal
pour autant est-ce que c'est la vérité
absolue et figé julia est ce que ça se
passe toujours comme ça voilà vous en
doutez non par exemple des fois on
trouve des spécimens aux dragons du
komodo qui se nourrissent en attaquant
de façon fourbe lemmy de certains
volatiles pour en manger les yeux en
fait il n'y a pas de vérité figée de
vérité idéal qu'on peut arriver à
pointer du doigt la réalité est bien
plus chaotique et la science permet en
construisant le savoir sur les épaules
des prédécesseurs de cerner une version
simplifiée de ce réel un modèle de plus
en plus précises et même les chercheurs
qui ne trouvent pas ou dans les
recherches aboutissent à des impasses
contribuer à cette grande démarche
scientifique en aiguillant les
recherches futures
s'il ya une chose que j'aimerais que
vous reteniez de cette présentation
c'est que au final la science n'est pas
affaire de vérité figé mais de proximité
avec le réel
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]